>> Sean: FROM ONE SWAMP TO THE
NEXT.
WELCOME TO "HANNITY."
WE HAVE A LOT BREAKING.
THE PRESIDENT JUST EXCORIATED
THE HOUSE SPEAKER NANCY PELOSI
RIGHT TO HER FACE IN A
CLOSED-DOOR MEETING AT THE
WHITE HOUSE HE CALLED HER A
THIRD-RATE POLITICIAN.
THE PRESIDENT IS RIGHT.
DERANGED, PSYCHOTIC RAGE OF SETS
OF HATE TRUMP AGENDA IS ALL THAT
MATTERS IN HER WORLD.
THE SPEAKER'S SLOPPY EXECUTION
LEAVES A LOT TO BE DESIRED.
TODAY WE SAW IT PLAY OUT IN REAL
TIME.
PELOSI AND HER COLLEAGUES ARE
ATTENDING A MEETING SURROUNDING
THE MINISTRATIONS POLICY IN
SYRIA AND THEY SAY A PICTURE
SPEAKS A THOUSAND WORDS.
ON TWITTER, THE PRESIDENT CALLED
IT NERVOUS NANCY'S UNHINGED
MELTDOWN.
AT THE VERY SAME TIME THAT PHOTO
WAS TAKEN, THE HOUSE VOTED FOR A
MEASURE SPEARHEADED BY PELOSI
REBUKING THE PRESIDENT'S
WITHDRAWAL OF AMERICAN TROOPS
FROM SYRIA.
SOME REPUBLICANS EVEN SUPPORTED
THE MEASURE.
HERE'S WHAT THE LAWMAKERS NEED
TO KEEP IN MIND.
PRESIDENT TRUMP, WELL, HE
PROMISED TO BEAT THE LIVING BEEP
OUT OF THE SO-CALLED ISIS
CALIPHATE.
NOT SO CALLED.
IT WAS A CALIPHATE.
HE REMOVED OBAMA'S INSANE,
RIDICULOUS DEMOCRATIC RULES OF
ENGAGEMENT THAT PUT HANDCUFFS ON
OUR TROOPS, AND GUESS WHAT.
HE BOMBED THE LIVING DAYLIGHTS
AND BEAT BACK THE ENTIRE
CALIPHATE IN SYRIA OF ISIS.
THAT'S A PROMISE HE MADE AND A
PROMISE HE KEPT.
PRESIDENT TRUMP ALSO PROMISED TO
GET THE UNITED STATES OUT OF ALL
FOREIGN CONFLICTS.
WE CAN HAVE ENDLESS WARS.
HE RAN ON THIS.
HE GOT SUPPORT FOR THIS.
IN SYRIA, WHERE WEAPONS OF MASS
DISTRACTION WERE USED, HE DIDN'T
DRAW ANY MEANINGLESS LINE IN THE
SAND LIKE OBAMA, HE ACTUALLY ACT
SAND LIKE OBAMA, HE ACTUALLY ACD
SAND LIKE OBAMA, HE ACTUALLY AC.
ANOTHER PROMISE MADE, ANOTHER
PROMISE KEPT.
LOOK AT THE NEW POLL.
MAJORITY OF REPUBLICANS DO
SUPPORT THE PRESIDENT'S DECISION
TO WITHDRAW TROOPS.
AMERICA'S WARS ARE NO LONGER
THOUGHT TO BE WON.
INSTEAD EVENTUALLY THEY'LL GET
POLITICIZED RIGHT BACK HERE AT
HOME.
DANGEROUS RESTRICTIONS ARE
PLACED ON HOW OUR BRAVE MEN AND
WOMEN, OUR NATIONAL TREASURE,
OUR SOLDIERS OPERATE.
AND THEN DISASTER ENSUES.
VIETNAM, IRAQ, AFGHANISTAN.
START THE FIGHT, POLITICIZED THE
FIGHT, THEN WE DON'T FIGHT
ANYMORE.
OUR NATIONAL TREASURE DIES.
THEY LOSE THEIR LIMBS.
THEY COME HOME DISFIGURED.
AND WE EVEN ABANDON THEM WITH
THE VA SCANDAL UNDER THE
OBAMA-BIDEN ADMINISTRATION.
INSTEAD OF ENDLESSLY PUTTING
BRAVE MEN AND WOMEN IN HARM'S
WAY, THE PRESIDENT, WELL, HE IS
SANCTIONING TURKEY FOR THEIR
AGGRESSIVE ACTION IN THE REGION.
IT HAD A HUGE IMPACT ON IRAN.
TONIGHT REPUBLICANS, YOU NEED TO
KEEP SOMETHING IN MIND HERE.
PELOSI AND HER LIBERAL FRIENDS,
THEY DON'T CARE ABOUT WHAT
HAPPENS IN THE MIDDLE EAST AT
ALL.
AND HOW DO WE KNOW THAT?
THEY ARE THE ONES THAT HELPED
START THE WORSE AND THEN WHEN
THE GOING GETS TOUGH, THEY ARE
THE FIRST PEOPLE TO POLITICIZED
THEM.
AND PUT HANDCUFFS ON OUR TROOPS
AND RIDICULOUS RULES OF
ENGAGEMENT DURING WAR.
WE ARE SUPPOSED TO WIN.
WE ARE SUPPOSED TO BELIEVE THEY
ARE HAWKS?
ON TOP OF THAT WE KNOW DEMOCRATS
ARE ONLY REACTING WITH RAGE
BECAUSE THEY ARE COMPLETELY
PREOCCUPIED WITH JUST SMEARING
TRUMP, BLUDGEONING TRUMP.
PELOSI'S RADICAL EXTREME
SOCIALIST SUPERVISORS IN THE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY, THE SQUAD,
THEY ARE DEMANDING THAT THIS
DULY ELECTED PRESIDENT OF THE
UNITED STATES BE THROWN OUT OF
OFFICE.
SHE WANTS TO KEEP HER JOB.
SHE IS DOING WHAT THEY SAY.
WITHOUT A DOUBT, THE LEFT HATES
TRUMP MORE THAN ANYTHING.
THEY'VE NOW CONVINCE THEMSELVES
HE IS SATAN INCARNATE AND THEY
WILL DO ANYTHING AND SAY
ANYTHING TO DESTROY THE
PRESIDENT EVEN ACT LIKE THEY ARE
REALLY HAWKS ON DEFENSE JUST TO
RUIN HIS AGENDA NO MATTER WHAT.
BY THE WAY, THIS IS WHY WE NEED
THE NEXT GENERATION OF WEAPONRY,
SO WE DON'T DO THIS TO AMERICA'S
TREASURE EVER AGAIN.
I WANT ANY FUTURE CONFLICTS TO
BE FOUGHT IN THE AIR-CONDITIONED
OFFICES IN TAMPA WHERE BUTTONS
ARE PUSHED IN THE ENEMY DIES.
OFFENSIVE WEAPONS AND DEFENSIVE
WEAPONS SO WE DON'T HAVE TO SEND
KIDS DOOR-TO-DOOR TO EAT THEIR
LEGS BLOWN UP AGAIN AND NOT GIVE
THEM ARMORED HUMVEES AND THEN
TREAT THEM LIKE CRAP WHEN THEY
COME HOME FROM INJURIES.
IF THIS PRESIDENT HELD
IF THIS PRESIDENT CELD
IF THIS PRESIDENT CURD
IF THIS PRESIDENT CURED CANCER,
THEY MIGHT IMPEACH HIM.
THIS IS HOW SICK AND UGLY AND
TWISTED IT'S GOTTEN.
IT'S A COMPLETE AND TOTAL WASTE
OF OUR TIME.
BREAKING LAST NIGHT, PELOSI
ANNOUNCED THAT THERE WILL BE NO
FORMAL ROLL CALL ON IMPEACHMENT.
THEY DON'T HAVE THE VOTES.
THAT'S BECAUSE THERE ARE ENOUGH
DEMOCRATS IN THE SWING
DISTRICTS, WE SCROLL THE NAMES,
THEY KNOW THAT IMPEACHMENT IS
THE END OF THEIR POLITICAL
CAREERS COME 2020, NOVEMBER.
BY THE WAY, THEY ALSO KNOW IT'S
A MANUFACTURED SCANDAL.
THEY KNOW FOR THEM IT'S
POLITICAL SUICIDE.
PAY CLOSE ATTENTION.
MAYBE THAT PERSON IS IN YOUR
DISTRICT.
THEY DON'T WANT TO GO ON THE
RECORD AS AN OFFICIAL ANTI-TRUMP
CONSPIRACY THEORIST IN A
DISTRICT THAT VOTED FOR
DONALD TRUMP.
LOOK AT THIS.
A BRAND-NEW FOCUS GROUP
FEATURING VOTERS FROM THE GREAT
SWING STATE OF OHIO SHOW JUST
HOW UNPOPULAR THIS IMPEACHMENT
HOLDS REALLY IS.
9 OF 11 PARTICIPANTS RAISE THEIR
HANDS TO SAY IMPEACHMENT IS A
DISTRACTION FROM THE ISSUES THEY
CARE THE MOST ABOUT.
SO NOW PELOSI'S SLOPPY STRATEGY
IS HITTING A SPEED BUMP.
HER TOP DEPUTY TO EAT THE
COWARDLY, SHIFTY ADAM SCHIFF
HOLDING SECRET MEETINGS.
I THOUGHT THEY WANTED
TRANSPARENCY.
DIDN'T THEY WANT THE UNREDACTED
VERSION OF THE MUELLER REPORT?
OH, NO DUE PROCESS FOR THE
PRESIDENT WHATSOEVER.
BY THE WAY, THE COWARDLY SCHIFF
EXPECTS US TO BELIEVE THAT AN
OFFICIAL IMPEACHMENT PROCEEDINGS
UNDERWAY.
BY THE WAY, HOUSE MINORITY
LEADER KEVIN McCARTHY POINTED
OUT SEVERAL BASIC CONSTITUTIONAL
RIGHTS ARE BEING DENIED DURING
THIS IMPEACHMENT SHAM FOLLOWING
QUESTIONS YET TO BE ANSWERED.
BY THE WAY, ALL THINGS
NEWT GINGRICH GAVE THE DEMOCRATS
WHEN THE REPUBLICANS WERE IN
CONTROL OF THE HOUSE WHEN REAL
IMPEACHMENT WAS GOING ON WITH
BILL CLINTON BECAUSE THE
INDEPENDENT COUNSEL SAW 11
FELONIES IN BILL CLINTON'S
CONDUCT AND IDENTIFIED THEM.
SPEAKER PELOSI, DO YOU INTEND TO
GRANT COEQUAL SUBPOENA POWER TO
THE CHAIR IN THE RANKING MEMBER
OF THE COMMITTEE LEVEL?
DO YOU INTEND TO REQUIRE ALL
SUBPOENAS TO BE SUBJECT TO A
VOTE OF THE FULL COMMITTEE AT
THE REQUEST OF EITHER THE CHAIR
IN THE RANKING MEMBER?
DO YOU INTEND TO PROVIDE THE THE
PRESIDENTS COUNCIL THE RIGHT TO
ATTEND ALL HEARINGS AND ALL
DEPOSITIONS?
DO YOU INTEND TO PROVIDE THE
PRESIDENTS COUNCIL THE RIGHT TO
PRESENT EVIDENCE?
DO YOU INTEND TO PROVIDE THE
PRESIDENTS COUNCIL THEIR RIGHT
TO OBJECT TO THE ADMITTANCE OF
EVIDENCE?
DO YOU INTEND TO PROVIDE THE THE
PRESIDENTS COUNCIL THE RIGHT TO
RECOMMEND A WITNESS LIST AND
FINALLY, DO YOU INTEND A
REFERRAL OF THIS TO JERRY NADLER
AND HIS COMMITTEE, CHAIRMAN OF
THE JUDICIARY COMMITTEE.
THAT'S ACTUALLY PRESCRIBED BY
THE RULES OF THE HOUSE.
OR IS THE COWARDLY SCHIFF IN
CHARGE OF LEADING THE INQUIRY AS
HAS BEEN REPORTED IN THE PRESS.
EVERY OTHER IMPEACHMENT
PROCEEDING HISTORICALLY HAS
FOLLOWED THE SIMPLE, BASIC,
FUNDAMENTAL RULES OF FAIRNESS
AND JUSTICE.
SPEAKER GINGRICH AFFORDED THOSE
RIGHTS TO PRESIDENT CLINTON AND
THE DEMOCRATIC MINORITY.
TODAY THE SPEAKER WON'T EVEN
HOLD AN OFFICIAL VOTE.
AS CONSTITUTIONAL LAW PROFESSOR
JONATHAN TURLEY PUT IT "PELOSI
SEEMS TO BELIEVE THAT SHE CAN
HOLD A PRESS CONFERENCE AND
EXPECT COURTS TO ACCEPT THAT A
FORMAL IMPEACHMENT PROCESS HAS
BEGUN."
WELL, SOME JUDGES ARE LIKELY TO
BE UNCOMFORTABLE WITH SUCH
IMMACULATE IMPEACHMENT.
VERY CREATIVE.
OUR OWN GREGG JARRETT, HE CALLED
IT A VENOMOUS AFFRONT TO
CONSTITUTIONAL PRINCIPLES.
BREAKING TONIGHT, ONE OF THOSE
CLOSED-DOOR HEARINGS, THE SECRET
CLIENT, THE PEOPLE THAT DEMANDED
TRANSPARENCY OF THE MUELLER
REPORT, SCHIFF PRESSURED A KEY
WITNESS TO LIE.
LOOK AT THIS BRAND-NEW REPORT
FROM THE "WASHINGTON EXAMINER."
ONE AMERICAN DIPLOMAT KURT
VOLKER REPEATEDLY REFUSED TO
AGREE WITH SCHIFF'S PHONY QUID
PRO QUO ALLEGATIONS.
SCHIFF SAID "AMBASSADOR, YOU'RE
MAKING THIS MUCH MORE
COMPLICATED THAN IT HAS TO BE."
I GUESS HE WASN'T GETTING THE
ANSWER HE WAS HOPING FOR.
THE LYING COWARDLY SCHIFF
DOESN'T WANT HIS WHISTLE-BLOWER
TO TESTIFY.
HE'S LIKELY CONCERNED THAT THE
NONWHISTLE-BLOWER WHISTLE-BLOWER
WILL BE FORCED TO ANSWER
QUESTIONS ABOUT THEIR CONNECTION
TO SCHIFF'S OFFICE AND THEY
ADVISE THEY WERE GIVEN BY
SCHIFF'S OFFICE TO GET AN
ATTORNEY AND GUARD THE
INSTRUCTOR GENERAL AND BY THE
WAY THE NONWHISTLE-BLOWER
WHISTLE-BLOWER'S WORK FOR SLEEPY
CREEPY CRAZY UNCLE JOE BIDEN.
HOW THIS WAS ESSENTIALLY FROM
THE GET-GO DEMOCRATIC LEAD SET
UP FROM THE BEGINNING.
WOW.
WE READ THAT BOOK BEFORE TOO.
AT LEAST ONE PROMINENT DEMOCRAT
IS NOW CALLING FOR THIS
NONWHISTLE-BLOWER WHISTLE-BLOWER
TO TESTIFY.